and we get it in so wait let me fix this
okay I don't know why the there it is
all right yeah let's
[Music]
go ladies and
gentlemen welcome
back to your favorite
podcast w
[Music]
G
baby what's up y'all welcome back to
Griffin with
Griffin today NBA preview season started
last night the rest of the games are
today they're probably going on right
now or not yet
um my buddy Hassan got this a little bit
of an issue I want to give you my
thoughts on it Britney's book is out and
there's Bombshells in it right plus news
notes from around the
world and as always welcome back
to with
g
[Music]
what up
y'all welcome back to riffin with
Griffin as always I'm a little late in
the day today and I'll tell you why
stuff going on in the Griffin household
all good um but anyways as always please
subscribe to the podcast I don't know
why it's making that flickering thing
but whatever subscribe to the podcast
cuz that's uh let's get away from that
you know um you know cuz that always
helps
depard when you subscribe to stay
alive uh you know twitch wait what's
going on here
twitch you know I'm always on Twitch so
you know check me out on my twitch
followers you know it's a good way to
also support the
show uh you know so I appreciate that so
make sure you check me out there and you
know for those people on patreon waiting
for that extra
content I promise you it's
coming know it's just like a joke to
myself right now but it's just like it's
hard dude I'm here by myself but I'm
working on I got some people helping me
with some stuff so CU I'm gonna be
around a lot it's probably gonna be all
baby content but I still want to do my
reviews but I like doing my reviews on
the podcast you know what I
mean ah welcome to all the people in the
live chat I appreciate you guys for
being here Live on YouTube sometime on
Wednesdays you know so and you guys are
here now so I appreciate that let's talk
about my dates coming up right off the
top so this weekend I'm going to be at
the comedy zone in
Greenville Greenville comedy zone 27 to
28th just Friday and Saturday four shows
so if you're in that area come check me
out and then I got a new show it's not
on my website but if you're in the Los
Angeles area I usually do my Eric and
friends in the small room at the lab now
I'm going to do it in the big room main
room improv November 1st it's a
Wednesday November 1st come check me out
and it's going to be I got a great show
playing Damon Wayne Jr Craig Robinson uh
Ian Edwards I got a bunch of great
Comics that are going to be on that show
I'm going to try it out in the big room
so if you're in the LA area a lot of La
people watch my podcast come check me
out on November 1st at the improv get
your tickets now they'll be on my
website soon but you can go to Hollywood
improv website to get the stuff there
just had this ollipop is messing with me
um and then November 2nd I'll be at the
Orlando
Improv just one night Orlando Improv so
let's do that one and then Sid Splitters
in Tampa November 3rd and 4th uh got
some other dates coming up but you know
for now that's what I got going on there
so you guys come check me out Eric
Griffin
Live come check me how do stand up I'll
be killing it out
there um what's going on so first things
up first things first been a you know
regular week for me um I got my car
everybody I'm going do a solid review of
the car after I drive her for a little
while but I got my car I got my Lucid
air uh touring Edition white um it's
kind of like this off-white color feel
like a old man man color but man I love
it it driv smooth like everything about
it is great and it really hooked me up
too so I got three years of my lease to
get Electrify America charging okay so I
got that so I just and you just pull up
to Electrify America plug that sucker in
and it just does everything for you
charges fast right so I can use my home
charger or I can use that so much range
it's so
luxurious uh I'm glad I made this choice
for lease it's the fanciest car I've
ever owned um but you know I wanted I
like electric cars I like all I like the
idea that you could get like updates and
the software and if the car somehow gets
better and all that stuff I love all
that it's the future that's the one
thing I like to spend my money on and so
you know I'm Le leasing this and we'll
see if I want to buy it at the end of
the lease or I'm going to they have a
SUV that's coming out but shout out to
Lucid they made the whole experience
great they you they they send you a u a
uber black or a lift black whatever
which whatever one it was but the fancy
car comes and gets you takes you out to
the uh their uh showroom in Torrance
then I walk in and then like the car is
like um you know on a on a you know it's
got It's got the car cover over it and
then they took it off and it was like T
and then the guy helped me like through
all the setup process it's really dope
like it's got face recognition so when
you sit down in the car you you know it
knows it's you so then it adjusts all
your settings you can use a key fob you
can use just your phone or they have
this like card I think Tesla does the
same thing you you know and the car just
knows you're there so you just walk up
to the car and the car
opens um and it's just on there's no on
switch it's like so like Hightech you
know and I love all that um yeah love
all that stuff so so look out for a
review of the car I will be doing that
can't wait to do do that uh because I'll
do like a what I'll do is I'll do a
video like a separate video I'll still
go live on my podcast and I'll just play
that video of the review of the car and
tell you how I what I think about I'll
give you my honest review about the tech
and everything like that but like I say
what I love about these like electric
cars now is like you know if there's
something kind of funky about some tech
they're working on it and then they put
out a over the air update as opposed to
like you know you got a gas car old
school whatever the technology is that's
it you know and then it it would always
be frustrating because then like you
know you have a 2022 and then 2023 they
got all these new trimmings and you're
like what I want that you know so that's
what I like about electric cars but
anyway whatever it is what it is you
know what I mean it's not for everybody
first world problems right so you know
you know whatever I can't feel bad for
everybody right so um and once again I
think I would be remiss not to say you
know I I still let me just call again
for peace peace in the Middle East like
we used to say when I was a young kid
peace in the Middle East you know I you
know I realize it's a difficult
situation you know it's like being
around a Jewish family and then also
having like I realized I didn't realize
how many Palestinian friends I have too
you know and it's like man war will be
terrible in that area it's just terrible
all the things that have already
happened so far is just horrible and my
support goes out to innocent victims of
this situation and I hope they can
resolve this conflict okay I really
do all right what else is going
on in the um Griffin household oh so you
know Rachel's six months we're close
we're getting close right so now we
setting up to nursery and like my office
is a mess with all my crap that was in
this spare bedroom now we're going to
make it into the nursery so which was
like originally Rachel's yoga room then
it became the multi-purpose room then it
became her Sho room then it became like
you know so now it's going to be the
nursery so now we moving everything out
of there and man what a process that is
but so we wanted to get this she wanted
to get this particular stroller so we
got this like and it was like you I'm
just telling you all you people that are
like pregnant and you're about to
purchase these kinds of things look out
for the deals man you really do got to
look out for stuff because so she wanted
to get this orbit stroller it's kind of
pricey because it's a whole unit it's
the car seat it's the bassinet it's this
it's that it's all this you know it's
like a six piece thing with all this
stuff right so if you go to the the the
actual website it's a a significant
amount of money right just for that then
they throw in some stuff whatever so
she's looking around and she finds
there's this other store it's like a
baby store that sells the
same the the same system right from that
company but you know they're like a
wholesaler whatever they they it's like
how you could get a orbit stroller at
Neiman Marcus or there's like a couple
couple of stores that you could get this
thing from so you could go to NE market
and they might have a deal where hey you
buy this stroller we throw in this but
it's not from the company's deal so so
she went to this other website I forgot
the name of it and turns out if you
spend a certain amount of money like the
price of the stroller they'll give you
$600 in store credit so I was like well
that makes sense cuz now we can like do
that and you get 15% off if you're the
first customer oh man I wish I could
remember the name of the store I should
give them a shout out right this is
terrible podcasting but so we did all
that so then then the stroller came like
this like literally like she ordered it
a day ago and then it showed up FedEx
today because they don't want you to
like change your mind when you spending
that kind of money they're like get this
stroller get send it full send full send
that stroller so we got the stroller and
then this is what I want to talk about
you ever like just the dudes out here
husbands feel me I'm we we got there's
like six boxes you have to un you have
to unpack everything okay right you
unpack everything first you take all the
plastic you put the parts you get the
the the the instructions and everything
Rachel want to just grab the wheel she
want to grab a wheel she grabs one of
the wheels and like okay we have to snap
this wheel in I'm like hold on woman can
we look at the instructions I mean it
was it was like oh my God you know what
I'm talking about it's like when you put
into something together I'm trying to
put this thing together I said we we
have to go one step at a time please and
then it turns into like well you know
you're yelling at me you know we have to
do this together as a family and I'm
like okay we oh my God and if anybody
feels me out there you
know
just give me a shout
out have you ever tried to put something
together with your wife and it just like
it it it goes three times as long
because of having to correct whatever is
going on like you trying to read the
instructions and she trying to skip past
it so but that was fun once once we put
it all together it was like I really
felt that that like butterflies in my
stomach kind of like I was pushing the
stroller around the living room like oh
my God I can't believe it so you know
knock on wood everything goes
well so anyways that was that little
tidbit of uh news that's going on oh
another quick news that's going on too I
can't believe like this is like they did
this they doing this fast guys but as
you guys know I directed Matt R's
Netflix comedy special and they already
have a preview so let's take a look at
it this is my Netflix directorial debut
y'all
[Applause]
I can't stand social media which I know
is crazy because it's why you're all
here if you ever eat someone's ass then
break up bro I would [__] with Grandma
in a heartbeat I know that's
gross tting the waters just seeing if
y'all are still fun just wanted to see
just wanted to
[Applause]
see no November 15th y'all November 15th
is coming out just wanted to I hope
you're a to he hear that I don't know if
my uh I never know if my thing is
working
right um yeah so anyways so that's
coming out so I'm excited about that
November 15th already you know what I
mean I hope I think it's going to be
huge for him uh you know he's just one
of the biggest comics in the world right
now just you know whether you think he's
funny or not whatever I just want want
to tell you the dude's a funny Charming
dude let me just tell you a quick story
about Matt R real quick just you guys so
you know and I'm doing we're doing a
documentary about him right now but
anyways I so we're out in um there's
like a video on the internet right now
of on his page where there was this
there was this old guy at the show right
this old guy was like outside his tour
bus and you know the guy was just
waiting and waiting and waiting and you
know and then you know Matt finds out
about it somebody tells him one of this
guys like hey do this's dude out here so
Matt goes out starts talking to him you
know and the guy's like the 74 year old
dude but he's one of these guys that
like sells autographs you know he like
he like it so he just he collects
autographs this is what he does you know
it's just everybody all the security
know him they're always kicking him out
they're always like all right too much
man right but he's just a sweet old man
right Matt gives him like extra tickets
to the show and puts him in a better
seat so now the guy sitting like Center
and like really great seats and then
like so at the end of the show Matt
calls me out and we're doing this like
crowd work together and then Matt's like
where's Fred you know so like you could
see the video on Matt's page and then
like you know the the guys it's like I
had this pillow of M I make a joke about
it and this girl's like I want the
pillow you
know and we go if you make out with Fred
you know we get the pillow and she's
like I'll do it I'll make out with him
so then it's like the crowd goes crazy
it's this fun moment you know what I
mean so then after the show we're
getting ready to leave we got to go to
the next city you know and then they
find Fred you know and Matt's talking
with him and you know Matt's grandfather
died his last special was dedicated to
his grandfather and I can tell I I Matt
has a soft spot for this you know so
then like you know we're filming him and
we're like you know to talk and whatever
then you know when we're done filming
you know Matt's like scr he finds out
that the guy this Fred he was $1,200
away from paying off his car car I don't
know how the conversation came up but
they just were talking and the guy was
like yeah you know I'm doing this and
that and I'm almost done paying off my
car and this and that so then Matt scres
together cash I had like 500 in my
wallet so I was he was like I'll pay you
back I was like all right I gave him the
money he found some other money from
other people we and he and he's gonna
give this old man he doesn't know $1,200
you know and I said well let's film it
and he goes no I don't want to do it
like that that's not why I'm doing it
you know and I was like cool and then he
goes and gives this guy
$1,200 the look on that old man's face
he was like he almost was like what like
what are you what are you talking about
you can't and the guy was just like he
couldn't believe it you know and and
then it just and I say to him later mat
I was I know why you did that he was
like yeah you know he looks he he he
looked very much like his grandfather
and it's something that Matt wanted to
do was to take care of his grandfather
so he became rich and famous
before his grandfather who he loved so
much his grandfather died before he
could do all the things that he would
have wanted to do for his grandfather
change his life you know what I
mean and so he gives this old man $1,200
you know and it's just like that's who
that kid is man I'm telling you love him
or hate him he is a genuinely good dude
and I am really happy that what
everything that is happening to him
right now is uh great you know and just
a testament to all of us of just like
you know just don't change be who you
are be genuine and then good things will
happen and you can um you know pay it
forward you know what I mean so it is
what it
is um but anyways guys um let's go to
the comments as we like to do let's go
to our comment section and I also have
have a you know poll not a poll but a
question and answer up for the people in
the chat if you want to say some things
all
right um Gregory Spike MD H hilarious
look everybody keeps going back to this
Matt R episode I had somebody says his
arms were so tiny back
then that's
funny
uh let's see here um no I'm not going to
read that one I had some good ones
somebody said why why you Whispering
Angela looking at the Bobby Lee and
Steve episode it's so
stupid uh de's nuts 1947 stupid name but
thank you it says love you
[Laughter]
Eric uh then let's see Ken Pachi white
707 says Griffin I know it's not your
thing but I want to see you play some
fighting games time to challenge
yourself you think Call of Duty makes
you angry just play some fighting games
bro let me tell you I have already done
that I played I I got when remember when
they redid Mortal Kombat like two or
three years ago I got that it it is just
when you play fighting games you could
play with your friends okay and then
that's fun because you're playing with
your friends but you're not always
playing with your friends so then you
got to go online now to play games and
you're just playing with 10-year-olds
with the fastest fingers in the world
and those fighting games are all about
these combinations it is not fun at all
there was another game too that was like
DC Universe like it was like DC
characters like Superman and and Wonder
Woman and all the DC characters and it
was like a Tekken uh um Street Fighter
type game where you fight you know that
I could never get you knowing all the
powers all the button combinations I I
can't do it I've tried and it was so
annoying waste of money spent $99 on
both those games waste of money can't do
it by the way it's the reason why I
don't like playing even playing like uh
uh Madden Online you ever tried to play
Madden online like it it seems like
everybody is an NFL offensive
coordinator in on the [__] thing man
everybody you play with is like knows
how to do everything and you just feel
stupid you get beat by 85 in a football
game so that's not fun
so I like Call of Duty because it gives
me an I feel like I I feel like I'm good
enough to to to hang you know and you
know you're playing with these like
sweatball pros so it's pretty fun
somebody said Martha the zebra said what
happened to Wiggly it's
Wiggly Wiggy Wiggy still around I talk
to him all the time it's just that we
don't live in the same area and he has
to come to come over here to do that I
was just testing it out seeing if I
needed a Jamie type person but it's hard
like in my place I you know and then
he's like so busy doing his own thing
wiig's like he like directs music videos
and documentaries and he's like like a
very busy kid too but he's also having a
baby he's we actually see having a baby
around the same time you know it's crazy
he we're like a week apart on our due
dates so that's pretty
crazy um let's see
uh let's see John Aquarius podcast he
said they might not be together but Jada
is still the mother of Will's kids so I
guess that's why will felt the need to
defend Jada's honor I don't agree with
his actions but I can see the motive
yeah I don't necessarily know if that
was the motive that night I don't think
he was defending her honor like you like
that's crazy if if you're going to
physically assault someone on National
Television on the most important night
of your entertainment career uh for
Honor over a dad joke then like he
should be fighting everybody right he
should just be on the streets fighting
people we should we should see reports
of Will Smith getting in altercations
all the time
cuz so I don't think that's what it was
that's not what it was at all what the
all the information that has come out
everything that she said we now know
that's not what it was so all the dudes
that are like we're saying that you
y'all look y'all are very mistaken that
he he didn't do that for his wife's
honor they they had even been together
for six years um anyways all right so
that's enough of these comments right
here uh let me go to the let me see if
there's anything in the Q&A that I want
to answer for you guys uh let's go to
questions let's see what we got
here uh oh somebody at U
muchy night away what I hate your names
guys I hate them yo what's up Griff
you're ever going to come back to the
Laugh Out Loud Comedy Club in San
Antonio yeah probably you know I was
just there like I don't know when that
was so I got to like you usually takes a
year a year to come
back uh stay smoking said are you scared
of being an old dad in quotes you are
having kid of a little late in life I
had my first kid at 25 so it's just
curious on your feelings good luck
brother you got this I you know what
that's a that's a fair question and I
think I've talked about it before but
I'll talk about it again just to answer
this question I do think about it but
what am I supposed to do you know it
like it is what it is you know I just I
just my life plan was just different it
just it happened the way it happened you
know and so here I am you know having a
kid
at my age and I'm just going to try to
do the best I can you know give the kid
as much love as I possibly can while I'm
still alive but I do think about it and
I you know I I want to it it does
inspire me to want to take care of
myself more so I could be around you
know for as long as possible and also
you know it's like you hear stories of
people being like you know you go to
their school and everybody's like oh is
that your grandpa like why is your dad
so old you know it's like all that kind
of stuff but for me like I don't know
any of it because I never had a dad so I
don't I don't even know what you're
supposed to do or not supposed to do or
what I was missing out on so all I could
do is just be as present as possible for
as long as I can and just give love
right that's because I think you know so
what my mom did for me as much as she
could having to work and do all that
kind of stuff so I just I'm looking
forward to doing all the things that I
never got you know I want to be I want
to pick my kid up from school you know I
want to be at the games I want to be in
the stands being like let's go or
whatever my kid wants to do even my kid
is you know Whatever It Is ballet figure
skating weightlifting uh you know
whatever it is I want to be there so but
thanks for the
question
um cloudy 17 hey gri just want to say
you're a cool dude all right I
appreciate
that uh oh so somebody said when will
the twitch Subs be able to play a custom
match together you know what you're
right okay I'm going to do it all right
I just I just get you you know how it is
it's so you know what I I'll actually
let me tell you what the real issue is
with that something's going on on my on
my Activision account where I can't
interact with other people and I can't
hear any proximity chat I can't I can't
add people to my games it's been going
on now for almost a year I put in two
count them two um uh support tickets to
Activision no response they start they
were responding at first and then it
just they just stop responding did a
second ticket nothing they don't care
they're not trying to help they they're
just like whatever hope it works out for
you um yeah so anyways all right guys so
that's um where we're at there with all
the question and answers appreciate all
that you know that was good good good uh
good interaction today from everybody so
let's get into the stuff I wanted to get
into today so first up I want to talk
about the NBA season that's out right
now guys you know you know
uh like this is going to be I don't know
what kind of season this is going to be
but you know we're talking about we're
coming to the end of an era of so like I
I'm old enough to remember the end of
Jordan era so when Jordan was with the
Wizards it was already like whoa this is
the end of greatness you know and then
but there was people there to take it
over it was Kobe it was
Shaq those people and so you we sort of
had that sort of Kobe Shack era and then
LeBron was he was you know he was coming
in he was going to be a rookie so then
we had this like we saw the people that
were going to take over the league you
know so that looked good uh now it's
like you know we're coming to the end of
LeBron's era man he's like got he's on a
minutes restriction I mean let's be
honest the dude gonna turn 40 during the
season I believe the fact that he's even
playing at this kind of level is like
wow amazing kudos to you but is it good
enough to to win a championship is it
good enough to like so he needs his team
and Anthony Davis last night he just did
not have a good game man he just he
doesn't look like a a MVP and he's got
to be the MVP the the team you know he's
got to be the MVP he's got to be the
best player on the on the team and he's
got to be in the top three players on
the court no matter who's on the court
his team or the other team he has to for
the Lakers to have a chance and he just
is so in consistent it's just very
disappointing but who's taking over the
league now man who's it going to be you
know you got johnar then all his off to
court issues uh Fatboy and um um um Zion
Williams you know is he gonna be they
thought he was going to be the one is he
gonna be the one who knows Jason Tatum
he's had his chances can't do it right
and then you got guys like James Harden
can't do it you have you know uh 76ers
guy uh uh the center you know it's like
you have all these people but none of
them really steeping forward and then
you and then now you have this like sort
of like other team in Denver that you
know so you got yic and you got Jam uh
Williams what is it no Murray Jamal
Murray so they look great they they won
the championship so they look good but
they're not like ah they're not exciting
if you're from Denver you love them but
the rest of us are like oh man I wish
some you they're not fun you know what I
mean but I love basketball and they're
tremendous in terms of like basketball
like if you're really into basketball
defense plays watching how they move
watching how they pass watching how they
play together if you're into that but
just like The Superficial your eye test
you're kind of like okay they they're
they're
boring but I think the guy that's going
to be the one is this Wim yamama am I
saying his name right from s Victor
Victor W the one is security guard slap
brne Spears is dude might be the one man
74 handles shot got that dog in him so
we'll we'll see so that he might be the
next thing but I just wish he wasn't in
San Antonio you know what I mean so
we'll see what happens there man so
right now it look it's looking like the
Denver Nuggets are the best team in the
league still so they're they're the team
to beat it's Denver Nuggets versus the
field man so we'll see what's going on
uh you know they got great players you
know of course they got jokic two-time
MVP could have been three-time MVP he
actually should have won last year
considering how he played Jamal Murray's
great he's back from his ACL he's still
great Aaron Gordon you know that guy
Aaron Gordon is like revitalized his
career he's the exactly the kind of
player he needs to be with a couple of
superstars and then he can shine his
defense and Michael Porter Jr so they're
looking good man Milwaukee Bucks I
haven't talked about it a lot but like
getting Dame Lillard with um uh an TMO
like this is it they an TMO already
proved he can win the championship even
though though that Championship was a
little suspect considering the injuries
of the Nets but whatever they did what
they were supposed to do when they
won uh so now you add Dame Liller who we
all think is a really fantastic player
he's been a fantastic player for his
whole career but now he's in a position
of where the pressure is on put your
money where your mouth is you know it's
like you got game it's Dame time he's
always tapping the the his wrist for
Dame time now it's Dame time show us
what you got now you there's no excuses
for neither one of those guys AO just
signed a long-term a three-year
extension so they're looking to win now
and I think that it's I think if we see
Milwaukee Denver in the championship I'm
not going to be surprised that's going
to be a
great uh you know thing what's next we
got some other teams I'm looking at
Boston Celtics always parentally good
now in the last seven years the Boston
sou are just always there they're always
but can they get over the hump that's
the thing but I like this team they got
Jason Tatum he's every year he's
maturing he's only 23 years old so maybe
now he could get it together um Jaylen
Brown they those are two all NBA players
right now Drew holiday who in the in the
the deal
for um Lillard he's he ended up now and
that guy was great with a championship a
ring on his finger and he was a big part
of that and then Christa porzingis who
like he reminds me of how Aaron Gordon
is for Denver porzingis was supposed to
be a superstar he's not but he is a
great addition when you have other
superstars so I think the Celtics are
right there too would not be surprised
if the Celtics were in the championship
and of course you got to go with the
Phoenix stuns you know you when you when
you accumulate this kind of talent in
one place how can you not think that
they're going to do
well hey Kevin Durant Devin Booker
Bradley Bill two three of the best
scorers in the league my question for
them is can they play defense and can
the rest of the team fill in the blanks
so we'll see but for right now they are
looking
delicious um so we'll see how that that
goes I mean I'm not a huge Kevin Durant
fan I just think he is who he is I think
that the injuries that he's I think his
mental it his injuries I think that I
think that his basketball acuum if
that's the right word is and his
intelligence about the game is greater
than his ability to play the game
because of age and attrition you know so
that's the tough part about where he's
at but I hope it works out I hope it
works out for him I'd like to see him
finally like you know live up to what
what we say that he is outside of Golden
State you know so we'll see I just don't
see Kevin Durant at that age as hard as
he plays as fast as he plays I just
think that he's going to be out 30 games
this year I hope I'm I hope I'm wrong
but that's just where I see it and then
you got like you know you got the Lakers
I I just I think the Lakers did a
fantastic thing last year can LeBron
stay healthy but if Anthony Davis
doesn't play like a freaking allstar MVP
caliber player Lakers have zero chance I
don't want to talk about them anymore
that's all we got and obviously go State
Warriors Golden State Warriors back in
the mix they got a great they got some
good players now they still got Steph
clay Wiggins Draymond Chris Paul who's
now starting but you know come on guys
is is Chris Paul gonna finish the season
is he gonna be available in the playoffs
I doubt it we'll see what's going on
with that man you know and then you got
the other honorable mentioned teams you
know you got the Knicks the Knicks you
know they're looking good I mean I'm not
a big Knicks fan but they played well
last year and this is a this is a a a
blue collar bunch of players they have
you know Brunson Brunson showed himself
to be like an MVP caliber player then
you got Julius Randle Barrett Josh Hart
you know we'll see how they do
man Philadelphia 76ers I heard today
James Harden is going to show up I think
that there's new rules in the NBA from
the collective bargaining agreement so
James Harden put he actually I was
listening to First Take today I think
James Harden messed himself up by by
saying he doesn't want to play for them
because he got lied to so then he
doesn't have any like leg to stand on
for not wanting to show up now he can't
be a free agent you know it's like I
think that this NBA owner is going to be
like no man you're playing with us you
don't want to play okay don't show up
we're going to save all the money that
we're going to save for for finding you
cuz he's losing salary every time he
doesn't show up so so I think he wants
to like be like whatever I think they'll
just like put him on the bench or
whatever like just who knows what's
going to happen with that but they're
not going to pay him the money that he
wants so we'll see uh but you know if he
is playing and playing well I think that
they're good somebody in the chat is
asking about Dwight Howard could help
the locker room I know if you guys know
but Dwight Howard's in a little bit of
trouble right now he's you
know anyways it sucks like you know it's
like who knows if whatever happened is
true or not I mean you know this that
kind of thing actually happens to
professional athletes all the time it ha
it happens actually a lot more than you
think people accusing professional
athletes of things and then it turns out
that it was a money grab I'm not saying
I'm not trying to blame victims or
nothing like that I'm just telling you
that that actually happens a lot more
often with those type of high-profile
they're out at a club somebody's like oh
my God you know and then they end up
settling because it's just easier that
way lawyers go just settle just pay pay
this person $100,000 and get out of this
you know whatever it is so this might be
one of those situations but who knows
and or you know but then it also has to
do with like another man so this man is
saying so then Dwight Howard had to come
out and be like hey
um I this was a consensual relationship
so he basically had to come out he had
he had to come say hey I'm gay or I'm by
or whatever just to sort to prove his
innocence you know and which is like
that's a terrible way for you to like
have your business out in the street but
it is what it is all right let's get
back to it Cleveland Cavaliers are going
to be good they Donovan Mitchell Darius
garland that Mobley Alan that that team
is but they just they need experience a
lot of these teams are great but they
just need some more experience Miami
Heat I just they the only difference
between Miami Heat last year and this
year even they made to the finals is
Tyler Heroes going to be healthy is he
enough I don't know I don't know we'll
see about that them Memphis Grizzlies
once again uh I think that um John
Morant is going to be suspended for a
few games like I think a lot of games so
we'll see what happens but they're
always a good team but again they need
experience can they get over the hump I
don't know we'll see and then my
clippers man Paul George Kawhi Leonard
Russell Westbrook listen I I always have
faith in my clippers Kawhi Leonard says
he's 100% healthy can they do it they
have the team they have the Talent they
have one of the best coaches in the
league they got a deep bench come on
Clippers but you know it is what it is
man Sacramento Kings final four last
year what you know um can they do it
again they were young they surprised
people I don't know if they're going to
surprise anybody this year but we'll see
what's going on with the Kings I love
them Oklahoma City Thunder dude this is
one of those other sleeper teams that's
like they remind me of Cleveland where
it's like they just got young players
and can they put it together and
surprise people but these guys are good
Shane Gillis Alexander I wish he was
still a Clipper that dude's good they
got some good players over there you
know uh Minnesota Timberwolves I don't I
don't believe I don't have any faith in
Minnesota Timberwolves I think Anthony
Edwards is a superstar could be MVP but
Carl Anthony towns he just is who he is
man he reminds me of proing pringus and
Aaron Gordon and these kind of guys that
were like oh this guy's going to be MVP
caliber you know perennial Allstar
some people are not meant to be the
alpha dog on a team but they are really
good right I think he's like that so
we'll see what's going on with that and
then last one I want to talk about is
this New Orleans Pelicans man this team
could be so
good Brandon Ingram McCullum if Zion
Williams can get hisself together that
team could be dangerous and ready so
we'll see what's going on with that guys
but anyways that's my NBA preview for
now and of course I'll still be talking
about the NFL and the NBA for the rest
of the season so we'll see how that goes
man all right let's talk briefly about
uh you know my I love talking about
Britney Spears because she's just like
so crazy man all this crazy stuff that's
going on so I saw this article about uh
you know she got her book coming out you
know what I mean Britney Spear's book
The Woman in me is a is full of
Bombshells from just Timberlake Madonna
Christia and the and then this this
article goes into excuse me the juiciest
moments I tell you guys I don't know why
people do this does she need the
money it's like why reveal some of these
things like she already revealed that
she had a abortion with Justin
Timberlake imagine you're Justin
Timberlake you're with your wife you got
your kid you know all your Playboy past
is what it is you were a boy band and
you did whatever you dated Britney
Spears maybe it didn't go well you guys
were young and stupid and then she
writes this sort of tell all book just
from her perspective and just putting it
out there like he's a monster right
she's just she goes in on just like it's
like so bitter like she just going in on
the dude and revealing all this stuff
then she revealed oh yeah Colin frell
and I we had rough sex it's like damn
does that need to be out there it's like
my God it's like every time you see
Colin farell now you're goingon to be
like oh you you be getting it in huh
Colin so she just really goes in you
know but she talks about Justin
Timberlake uh you know and uh they
terminated a pregnancy it was a
surprise uh she just goes in Spears of
she cheated on him with choreograph Wade
Robson and he's the guy that was
accusing Michael Jackson by the way that
case thrown out again for like the
hundredth time the this guy has no
evidence and you know he keeps changing
his story whatever that's a whole other
discussion so she cheated on Justin with
that dude okay uh she was like I was
loyal to Justin for years only had my
eyes for him with that one exception
which I admitted to him you know just
that I moved past stay together uh then
he go timlake allegedly cheated on
Spears to there was a couple of times
during our relationship when I knew
Justin cheated on me I mean what were
they in their early 20s like what you
know both of them pop stars both of them
like some of the most famous people in
the United States like I'm not condoning
it I'm just saying like they both what
were they doing together was it real
anyway I mean it's just young love man I
just don't know when you look back on
young love and write about it and then
and the way the way Society works now is
whatever you did wrong before that's who
you are for the rest of your life if
they bring it up again you know which
sucks people grow they change they were
young and stupid now she's old and crazy
it's you know what I
mean all
right next week we're going to go into
uh football guys um yeah then she talks
about Christina
Aguilera they were often pitted against
each other uh you know what I mean which
is
crazy yeah I it this is
like she goes in that story she said she
thought Justin and I should get back
together which was just confusing given
how negative she'd been elsewhere Spears
wrote even if they weren't trying to be
cruel I felt that they were just pouring
salt in the wound why was it so easy for
everyone to forget that I was a human
being vulnerable enough that these
headlines could leave a bruise man I
think she's an example of not everyone
some people have Superstar talent but
not everyone has that thing to survive
the media and the pressure and all that
and it looks like all that got to her
she goes in on Madonna she talks about
her famous romances Colin
Ferell
um she goes in on her her Kevin fedeline
the father of her kids you know what I
mean uh she go she talks about some all
her love I mean she just really goes in
she talks about drugs and
partying um SP said it was never as wild
as the Press made out to be during her
clubbing days in the mid 2000s however
she admitted her drug of choice at the
time was ADHD medication ater all which
said made me high yes but what I found
from more appealing was that it gave me
a few hours of feeling less depressed
it's like okay I I I depression is like
I'm not going to clown anybody's
depression or mental health CU like it's
such a nuanced thing B that's so
individualized you know what I mean you
know you know what I'm saying like it's
like like because from the outside
looking in you're like what you know
you're taking ater all you're rich
you're famous you act you're out
clubbing with other famous girls having
a good time having sex with Colin
Ferrell yourfriend boyfriend's Justin
Timberlake you would see all that and be
like man what what why isn't that you
know what's going on with you but
obviously people get depressed about so
many different types of things so she
talks about her acting career what
acting career are you kidding
me of course the media and then she goes
into this about this conservatorship
which I think was terrible
but who knows now what do we even know
like she was she was in this thing for
13 years I mean clearly taken advantage
of treat it like a a prize Pony just put
out like if you're in a conservative
ship should you be like doing
concerts that you don't have control
over any of your life oh man every time
I think about that I just but we don't
never know if it was necessary or not
but anyway it's I I actually want to get
the audio book and check it out because
it's like you know the the random crazy
thoughts at Britney Spears I'm sure it
was like like what was this about huh so
you know it is what it is
y'all all right last thing I want to
talk about is just like a old buddy of
mine I mean I haven't talked to him that
much since he got famous and I'm not
saying that to be like oh I don't you
know I don't want to I don't want to
uh like I'm not distancing myself from
the guy because I totally get it but you
know the comic Hassan how do you say
Hassan's last name
I don't know how to say his last name so
I'm not going to butcher it but I don't
know if you guys have heard this story
but you know so he's a comic and he's
like he's very much like a political
comic now too I me he did the
correspondence dinner roast thing you
know and he was fantastic but he was
going in he went hard you know I would
say he's left leaning Arab descent comic
and you know so in his specials he talks
about things that have happened to him
like racial events and things like that
and then they did this article in the
New Yorker to come to find out that he
made up a lot of the stories you know he
made them up these things didn't really
happen to him but then you know there's
this the the girl that he claimed oh she
didn't want to go to prom with him
because of who he was because of his
race you know turns out that girl
actually married she was she already had
a prom date and she married a dude just
like him right so she got an Indian
boyfriend husband now you know so it's
like but all right two schools of
thought I want this is why I want to end
with this okay how do I feel feel about
this how do I feel about what he did or
what this is even
means the first thing is this as a comic
myself if you think everything the
comics say is true okay or if you feel
like everything they say should be true
and they made this thing funny okay I
can see why you would think that I I'm
not as a comic I don't think that that's
how it should be I think that like you
know you have a foundation of like okay
this happened and then you embellish you
know like if you're talking about your
wife and that's your joke and your wife
did a thing you might add a couple of
things to the story because it makes it
funnier that's just what we do we're
storytellers you know that's part of
part of it you know it's always great
when like the thing is like 100% true
that's always great you know like I talk
about some things that Rachel has done
and she they they're like dead on what
she's done it just happens to me that
those things are funny but there's
occasion where you like get add of
things you add some stuff and I think
that I don't think there's anything
wrong with that because you know we're
performers you know we're acting really
you know so but there are people that
feel like no everything the comic should
say it should be a th% true okay I I
understand why you feel that way I don't
feel that way okay and I as a comic and
I have done that I've like when you're
you're make you're talking about
something but not like this though you
know um so that that's so that's so then
I don't agree with what he did and like
especially if if you're talking about
someone specific and then that person
could get backlash for that it's one
thing to make up facts it's one thing to
like that that are just surrounding you
but when you do it like that and then it
gets back to people I don't like that so
I and then and then to have this thing
where it's like well these things didn't
happen to me but it's my emotional truth
I don't like that I think just own it
just like just own it because here's my
next point about what I really think
about this is you know this is just a
sign of the times for like more liberal
sensitive people these people are so
easily
manipulated Hassan weaponized cancel
culture he weaponized it and he made it
a part of his set because he knew all
the people people that subscribe to this
that think that the the the victimhood
and and how racism is everywhere and how
abuse is everywhere and how the white
man is terrible and how white people are
terrible that side of the country which
is includes a lot of white people saying
this too you know what I mean he
weaponized that for financial gain
because he knew if you just say this
stuff that side goes oh my God I can't
believe this happened because they don't
really care they just want to announce
to everyone that they're a good
person I'm a good person so I'm going to
support him and his comedy because I
can't believe that that happened to him
and then they put it on internet and
they're like looking at all their
friends like right look how what a good
person I am the
left those type of people and it's not
all left but it just for the most part
it seems to be it's all this sort of
Lefty you know uh Progressive type
people y'all are so easily manipulated
you should be furious at him because of
that this is just like Jesse
smette he was going through whatever he
was going through and he said oh I know
what to do I'll just claim I was gay
bashed and then all the left will be
like I can't believe this is happening
in our country and and then they start
doing that he no proof this is my
problem with that side
they don't need proof they don't need
facts they don't need they don't care
about due process all they care about is
letting everyone know how they feel
about
things that's wrong that person's the
devil cancel that person and then they
move on right now because of what he was
talking about and saying this emotional
truth thing this other side is so
[__] stupid that they they don't like
they don't even realize how they were
manipulated they're sitting there and
they're going like oh yeah emotional
truth is real bro no it's not okay we
cannot live like
that we cannot the fact that he had to
make all this stuffff up because he felt
oh this would be great for material and
people will eat this
up that's a sign that we're actually
doing better than you think we can't
make everything about being a victim we
can't make everything about racism and
sexism and we can't make everything
about that there are instances where
these things are going on and we should
we should do something about those
things but let's not make it like
blanket like the whole world is terrible
but man y'all need to wake up if you're
on that side if you're such a liberal
person that all you're doing is looking
for you know uh people not saying the
right pronouns and you're looking for
any Act of racism and sexism any Act of
abuse and you and you want to just jump
on it to just to be like hey look I am
against that if you're one of those
people man you are so easily
fooled and that's what he did I wish he
would just own that I wish he would just
come out and be like yeah well I mean
you know what it's so like this is what
that side wants they buy tickets you
give them what they want whether it's
true or not and they'll come out in
droves just to be like I support you I
mean it's like because you're so easily
fooled by that it's time
to wake up let's get back to having due
process let's get back to like hearing
the facts let's get back to like you
know hey is this true explain to me why
let's get back to uh uh uh innocent
until proven guilty let's get back to
that
okay all right guys
excuse me I just I hope that you didn't
hear that in the mic because it probably
disgusting whatever that sounded
like but yeah man thanks for being here
for riffing with Griffin next week I'm
probably going to try to do real world
advice from a um grown ass man I want to
get that back um if you want to send me
a beat you know all you budding
producers you know send me a beat I got
this guy's name is JJ Fisher
he sends me a lot of dopee Beats man I
love this kid and so like right now I
haven't even heard this beat and we're
going to use this new beat for uh for
the um for the for the rap recap but
once again I just want to remind
everybody about my dates this weekend
I'll be in Greenville at the comedy zone
in Greenville October 27th and 28th and
then November 1st at the Hollywood
improv the main room I got a my ER
friends got some good buddies coming out
really funny dudes coming on that show
and chicks um improv in Orlando November
2nd I really want to sell this out so
one night only in Orlando come on out
guys and Sid Splitters in Tampa November
3rd and 4th so that's my little Florida
run right there and then some other
dates I'll be out there doing some stuff
so come check me out and make sure you
check out Matt R special on November
15th natural selection directed by youro
Boy
all right
y'all okay okay just that new
beat woo fishy make you move your
feet uh with that
rap here we go you know where it's
at woo NBA is
back Lakers looking
whack Denver on the
attack Milwaukee they got my
back Britney's Buck is
out she gave a lot of negative shout
out doing it
right that's
right my
boy that [__] did it
wrong yeah yeah
yeah I see you next
week I love
this him on your and
go all right y'all thanks fishy for
another dope be and I'll see you
guys next
week